you have skills as an actor and there
are things you need to do as an actor
that don't come up in my life for
example you kiss these women on screen
oh yes there's a reason I'm I don't do
that for living no woman wants me to do
that but I read the other day that
Brooklyn Decker is one of those
beautiful men in the world they asked
her who's the best kisser that you've
ever worked with and she said Adam
Sandler oh that was gonna be a high
compliment first of all she's better
she's a great nice person and and and
and her house she didn't she didn't have
to say your name well it was nice of her
to say that but she meant I was a
gentleman like I am a very cordial
co-star the mouth stays sealed
aye-aye-aye aye-aye-aye I don't move
much I let her do all the MU I stay kind
of if you watch my moving my eyes are
wide open and a kiss like you see you
stay very still I was open mouth shut
- yes Tony your your wife your lovely
wife is a critic of your on screen she
wants me to go harder she wants good a
few what she wants me to go harder with
the kissing she loves Aniston Jennifer
Aniston in this movie we got a person in
the movie and she wants you when you're
kissing Jennifer Aniston your wife is
telling you what go get it yeah my two
daughters I like come on be nice to
Jennifer kiss are good and but the
iSAGEN a all lager Addison is a good
friend of my family now so the day I had
to kiss her were kissing a Ferrari and I
have to lean and kiss her I think we did
six or seven takes and yeah after each
one it was I was getting stoned silence
at the monitor I'd come back to my wife
and kids they'd be like hey what I think
I did good on that one no daddy I had a
moustache gonna hurt her I'm never good
at that stuff to kissing but when it's
in the privacy of my own home you should
see me go guys
I sounded like an invitation the entire
studio audience meeting in you you can
do it